fête de l'internet aujourd'hui et demain
dans toute la france dans des dizaines
de lieux vous pouvez vous initier
gratuitement à ce réseau mondial de
communication reportage accessoires de
l'es9 bastide
l'image est officiel les inédites le
ministre de la culture qui décorent des
informaticiens des ingénieurs et
techniciens et la reconnaissance par
l'état de l'importance de ces nouveaux
acteurs de la société de l'information
1998 indique matin catherine trautmann
doit être lantin de l'internet grand
public
qu'on le veuille ou non ce réseau
mondial d'information va bouleverser
notre vie quotidienne des citoyens et de
consommateurs on est rentré dans une
nouvelle logique post industrielle avec
tout ce qu'il ya virtualité échange
mondial d internet fait partie
en fait de cet environnement
en quelque sorte avec des moyens de
communication de nous et qui permettent
de rapprocher les gens à travers
l'espace
si seulement quatre pour cent des
français utilisent internet à domicile
l'immense majorité pense que c'est un
formidable moyen d'après au savoir et
dans voici ce que nous avons trouvé en
quelques minutes sur le site du
ministère de la culture la restauration
d'un tableau de philippe de champaigne
la dernière bd de blake et mortimer les
1800 photos des héros de la commune de
paris
les plus belles heures de france comme
ici celle de corbeil dans les ctom ce
site est consulté chaque mois est
millions perdre votre image forte de
cette journée l'enthousiasmé des enfants
qui découvrent internet dans les salons
de l'assemblée nationale ouverte au
public
sur le moyen âge c'est tout et on peut
avoir des choses comme ça alors un petit
clic sur une souris et vous naviguerez
sur le web à des coûts de partir en
week-end offrez vous ce premier voyage
donne libéraux monde